[Music]
Ruth I'm so glad to be here with you
today and as we learned from Laura's
amazing introduction Ruth grew up close
to Stanford where her father was an
engineer at the original slack Stanford
Linear Accelerator Center and her mother
was a psychologist Ruth thank you so
much for joining us today we're all
familiar with Google just a quick poll
who here has used Google search today a
hundred percent how about who here has
worked or will work at Google Wow ten or
so excellent how about her yeah who here
has been in way moe or in a way Moe
self-driving car okay so four or five
who here would like to try out a way Moe
self-driving car we're back to 100%
so Ruth it looks like we have some beta
testers for you here today if you need
them perfect there's so much to cover
from your early beginnings to Morgan
Stanley - now alphabet in Google so
let's jump in before your parents landed
here in Silicon Valley they had a very
very difficult journey and your father
fled escaped with his life from Austria
in World War two how was your family
history shaped your values well probably
the most important thing my father
always said is that education is your
passport for life and the reason he said
that was very much to your point he fled
Austria having been thrown out of high
school he's Jewish and was fortunate to
be one of the few to get out his family
did not he was young enough that he was
on one of the youth boats went to
Palestine and as soon as he could he
enlisted in the British Army and while
he was actually fighting in the British
Army it occurred to him that if he ever
wanted to live in a place where there
was freedom for him and hopefully a
family that he would one day have he
needed a skill that people would value
and he concluded that that would be
physics and so somehow while fighting
the British army he started to teach
himself physics he sold his cigarettes
and somehow got material to teach
himself physics and his fellow soldiers
would tease him and say you're gonna die
before you can ever use this and his
answer was always I would rather die an
educated man and he told us that story
frequently and it made it hard if we
didn't do really well in school because
like I didn't even have the benefit of
all this stuff so he should do really
well but it was a really important value
one the importance of education and two
the gratitude to be in a country where
you do have freedoms that so many people
don't have and so those are probably the
most profound my mother was amazing a
psychologist and I remember as a very
young girl I was born in England and
I'll never forget the day I was 8 my
sister was 6 I know that because it was
shortly before we moved back to
California and she said you know it's
very important as a woman to have a
career just telling an eight-year-old
and a six-year-old that which he thought
was a perfectly normal time to give you
career advice but she made the point
that every cent she made went to her
nannies she worked and I think there was
part of her that felt this guilt that
many of us feel that she was working a
lot but she was also talking about the
gratification she got in which it meant
for her to be able to work with others
and why it was important to find one's
passion so I think they very much shaped
Who I am and I'm eternally grateful to
them you took the commitment to
education and career of course seriously
you graduated with three degrees in 1987
when you graduated from Wharton with
your MBA you accepted an offer at Morgan
Stanley to join the mergers and
acquisitions group the hottest role at
the time women a few weeks of joining
the stock market declined biggest
decline in Wall Street history how did
that how did that shape shape your
experience or what did you learn from
that experience well it was pretty
terrifying I started in August of 87 in
October of 87 on a percentage basis was
the biggest decline ever and so I sort
of thought my career was over before it
had even started and when I joined
Morgan Stanley I was of the view that
would only do mergers and acquisitions
like I just knew that's what I was
interested in and I would rather leave
the firm than do something else but of
course markets change an opportunity has
changed and probably the one of the most
important things is somebody I really
respected who I had worked on a deal
with said hey we're gonna create this
new thing it's gonna be covering private
equity firms it hasn't been done on Wall
Street before and at the time I thought
it was a really bad idea and why would I
want to go do that so I said I would
hedge my bet and do it half time and
within no time realized it was a really
exciting thing to do and it was the
first time I realized that if you're
working with people who are really smart
and take a risk on you they may open
doors that you don't even appreciate our
doors to be opened and it I didn't use
the word sponsor back then it probably
took me another decade or two to
appreciate that's really what I was
looking for but it it led me to another
place that I hadn't expected and I think
the willingness to be flexible and
adjust as the world adjusts or as you
adjust or as your life requirements
adjust was probably one of the most
important things I didn't have an option
the world changed but fortunately I
wasn't rigid one of one of the
statistics that comes to mind is that
for us many of us are about to graduate
and half of us switch jobs within five
years of graduation and you mentioned
and you mentioned sponsor or the idea of
sponsorship and you yourself switched
out of Morgan Stanley to join Smith
Barney following a sponsor and you've
noted in the past that you immediately
regretted that move so how health us how
did you recognize and fix your perceived
mistake so I choose to say that that
period of my life didn't actually exist
but you're taking me there
thank you for indulging me so two of the
people I worked really closely with
we're leaving Morgan Stanley and asked
me to go and actually run this private
equity coverage group which it seemed
like a wonderful step up and it could be
really exciting but I really loved
Morgan
in fact my father said he was surprised
when I chose to leave because I loved
the ethics of Morgan Stanley that was
the word that he chose to focus on at
the time I was pregnant with our second
child and a managing director at Morgan
Stanley in front of me at one point had
said to a client women may come back
after their first they never come back
after their second and I was terrified
that what had been a really great career
where people were looking out for me
might get derailed quickly because maybe
the people I've been working for men
because they were so few women back in
the day in leadership positions maybe
they got it and they had ethics but
maybe this thing I had heard was more
pervasive and I I kept hinting that I
was concerned my career wouldn't stay on
the pace it was and nobody quite got the
hint nor did they know I was pregnant
and that's why I was really concerned
and so I left and after a couple of
months I said you know the culture is
different and I want to be back at
Morgan Stanley and I went back and I
actually spoke to the CEO and said
here's here's the subtext I never shared
openly which of course his immediate
response was that's ridiculous of course
we want you back and yet because 40
people followed after I did the door was
shut and the lesson to me is if you're
thinking about switching put everything
out there the worst thing that can
happen is someone will tell you sorry no
I'm you know I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
honor that which you want and you should
go but you might actually find they do
and if you find that they do you end up
having the choice you want and if you
find that you didn't so they didn't you
don't have any regrets cuz at least you
know you tried the reason I was able to
go back is another really important
lesson of those 40 people I was the only
one who got the opportunity to return
and I think it really goes to this
mantra I lived by which is the world is
small and life is long and so make sure
everything you do you do in a high
quality way and so that enables people
to say I should come back at a certain
point and I got the call three years
later but it was there was so much in
there and anytime someone's coming and
telling me they want to switch careers I
tell them this story
put it all out there make sure you've
left nothing unsaid because you might be
surprised and people might say you know
what you're you're wrong and you should
come here and or here's a better
opportunity here and you'll never regret
it
thank you that will be helpful for the
two of a hundred of us switching jobs in
a few years time so let's fast forward a
bit it's September in 2008 by this time
you have proven yourself at Morgan
Stanley many times over holding many of
the titles that Laura read one of which
was vice-chair of investment baking but
also the economy is tanking Hank Paulson
gives you a call
asks you to please help him save the
financial system wasn't lee an advisor
to the US Treasury yeah thank you yeah I
need your color so please could you
please ugh walk us through that
experience and what you learned well it
was so July it was actually July of OE
he called and said I I need some help on
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac understanding
what's going on with the housing crisis
and so team and I went down to the
Treasury Department and of course July
of o8 shortly before the election our
question to him was do you want to kick
the can down the road to the next
administration or do you want to deal
with this and his comment was I don't
think we have time I'm concerned there's
gonna be the proverbial run on the bank
let me understand when Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac will not be able to fund
themselves anymore and this was a five
trillion dollar balance sheet in the
aggregate and his concern was were we at
the brink and and he basically said
analyze every component of it what's the
funding what's the capital what can we
do what are the options and that's what
we did around the clock until September
looking at what were the alternatives
how stressed was the housing market what
did it mean what was the risk what were
the options and it was extraordinary
seeing him in action and there are so
many lessons learned you can't learn
while you're
in that was that you have to have the
team that actually has instinct based on
experience and it really informs how I
think about the type of team I pulled
together I want to have a mix of people
who are extraordinary entrepreneurial
will walk through any wall because they
don't know you're not supposed to walk
through any wall with people who have
what I call battle scars they've seen
three four or five chapters ahead and
it's that mix that enables you I think
to come up with creative but
implementable solutions and so we
literally went around the clock till
September then announced the
conservatorship as it was called the the
path forward for Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac and went around the globe because
his his concern at that point was we
need to make sure every central bank
that holds US Treasuries or these
securities understands that we're really
protecting their holdings and in US
Treasuries and what's going to happen
with the economy and came back from that
and that was kind of step one and what
continued to be a pretty painful fall
why did you decide to join that team it
sounds I mean you're not one to shy away
from work but it sounded particularly
precarious well it was there was more to
it than than that and it sort of goes
back to your first question about my
parents when we were asked if we would
advise the US Treasury one of the
questions I was asked by the senior
leadership team at Morgan Stanley at the
time is if we were not advising the
government what would we be doing for
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and what
would the fees be to be quite blunt
about it you know if we were advising
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and their
initial conclusion was we probably
shouldn't take on this assignment and I
remember saying there are certain times
in history where there's only one right
option and this is the wrong option and
fortunately one of the people who is
still at the firm whose extraordinary
completely agreed and the CEO had
already gone out to make a call to Hank
Paulson to turn down the assignment when
we had this second round of
conversations fortunately Hank to
not pick up the phone and so we came out
and said you know there's only one time
there are times in history there's only
one choice and you must speak up and you
must do the right thing and in my view
was that was one of those times if we
were being asked to help at a time that
was so precarious for not just the US
economy about the global economy and we
had skills that would be relevant we
should we should serve so message there
is easier voice you're at the table
because people want your voice and I
think it's very easy sometimes to forget
that or not be sure you're actually
saying something the right way the
number of times I've said something and
then I go home and I say did I say that
the right way maybe I could have said it
better and then you're like you know
what
don't keep second-guessing make sure
though that if you have a point of view
the reason you're being hired is people
want your point of view it's really
important for me learning thank you so
moving moving a little bit ahead -
there's so much to cover I think so you
tell me let's see so February 2015
also correct my days upon writing the
Morgan Stanley ship you went on to serve
as CFO for five years you consulted
Silicon Valley executive and coach Bill
Campbell about what you might do next
you've reportedly told him that you
didn't want another CFO job correct I
was very clear minded about that what
made the Google CFO job different or
compelling so you you've got the
chronology right I've sort of gone
through coming out of what was a really
painful period for Morgan Stanley as
well and we worked over the ensuing
number of years to really position
Morgan Stanley I think quite well I
think the CEO James Gorman is
extraordinary and it was wonderful
working with him but I sort of reached
that point where I said you know I I
want an I don't want to look back in
five years and say why did I do that
next five years and what's the next
mountain that is out there that's going
to be really exciting that I can be
proud of and to leave Morgan Stanley and
CFO there and like I don't want to just
go do that
and so I thought I knew I didn't want to
just do that I didn't want to be a CFO
and so I went to Bill Campbell an
extraordinary person book just came out
about him the trillion dollar coach that
really gives his words of wisdom and it
was really just to get some guidance how
to think about what that next chapter
might be and he did ask me so do you
want to be CFO I'm like no bill one
thing I know is I don't want to be CFO
and he kept returning to that question
and after about two hours he ended with
that question so the one thing you know
is you don't want to be see if I when I
said correct and he said then I have the
perfect job CFO of Google and literally
within a second I said well if you're
serious of course I'm interested in that
and as I told you change I'm flexible so
it hadn't even occurred to me and it you
know Google was the company that I had
loved for a really long time first
invested fortunately through an angel
fund in 1998 was part of the IPO back in
2004 thought that you know thought and
think the founders are extraordinary the
mission is really inspiring and so it I
left his home still not believing it was
possible but it was it's just a it's an
amazing place to be when you joined
Google was known for its slogan don't be
evil less so it's processees arguably
and you had the way to financial rigor
including by having managers set
business milestones and even factor in
the cost of employee stock options into
their budgets something they hadn't been
doing before this was leadership in the
truest form it wasn't easy and it wasn't
popular your focus on return adjusted
innovation earned you nicknames like
ruthless I'm called Ruth full last week
it was not bad I'd like that like
progress it's very creative of them and
this was this was from people who were
accustomed to a more freewheeling
culture how did you balance the
trade-off of instilling discipline with
the appearance of curtailing Google's
innovative side
well first I think if I did not believe
in my core which I do that investing for
the long-term is what every leader
should do I wouldn't survive there and I
wouldn't be accepted but I think that
what I've seen throughout my career is
that if you don't invest for the
long-term you're actually sowing the
seeds of your own destruction
and I actually learned that really early
on at Morgan Stanley I had the
opportunity to work on an M&A deal the
hostile defense of Gillette and that
deal was subsequently written up in the
book from good to great and the reason
was so that was the subject of this
hostile takeover we were asked to find a
way to defend them but the CEO at the
time Colin McClure I'll never forget it
the most extraordinary man said you can
do anything you want but you can't touch
my R&D budget and I will not tell you
what it's for but I will tell you that I
do not want to be independent if I do
not have those R&D dollars and at the
time it was frustrating or like we need
some of it we've got to have some of it
and he was adamant we were able to keep
the company independent and years later
only years later did we learn that was
the sensor raiser and he was right when
he said without that R&D budget without
planning for the future it's just not
worth it so the most important point is
I do believe it's imperative to invest
for the long-term I think the other
thing is people need to make choices and
that sort of goes to the financial
crisis I learned so many things working
with Hank Paulson one of the things he
said was that you have to have the the
will and the means and too often by the
time you have the will mainly the
political will you no longer have the
means and when I moved out here from New
York and I was often asked about the
financial crisis I thought that was a
bit odd because things are glorious and
growing out here and that's very
different than the days in the financial
crisis but then I realized that some of
those lessons were as relevant here as
they were during the financial crisis
which is don't waste the really good
time and spend without or invest without
care - whether it's a great idea or a
mediocre idea just because you can put
your effort
the things that matter make sure that
you when you have the means you also
have the will and so all I was trying to
do and have been trying to do is create
the visibility into the data so that our
amazing business partners can make the
choice it's not me making the choice I
think that would be grossly arrogant to
think that if you're not the product
leader you know how to stack rank all of
the incredible things you're working on
but until people have the data it's hard
to make the choices and there's a phrase
also at alphabetic google anchor
everything in data and the rest will
follow
so my goal was actually to just give
them the data in a way that helped
people better understand how much they
were putting behind each each of the
various options so they could then make
choices and stack rank now obviously
unless you squeeze the envelope tight
enough nobody has to make choices so
that's where probably the some of the
nicknames come in but but but it for all
of you the tools that you have the
skills that you learned here the ability
to lay things out clearly if you anchor
everything in analytical rigor the data
should help guide the best decision
making was that something that you had
also done when you took on the CFO role
at Morgan Stanley is that is that
something that you had to implement in
place or was it there oh I think that on
every every assignment that I worked on
as a banker my view is let's start at
with the question to whoever the claim
is here's my understanding of your
hierarchy of objectives do I have it
right like I want to hear what people
are solving for and it can be
intellectual it can be emotional
whatever it is
what's your hierarchy of objectives once
you know what you're solving for you can
come up with a solution and then the
answer has to be able to be in my view
presented with analytical rigor because
numbers are a way of framing what's the
opportunity to set what are the
trade-offs what's the downside potential
but the numbers actually
the clarity of thought like one of my
dad's lines again when I was a little
kid he he came home from slack and he
said if a physicist in his lab could not
define a quark in less than 60 seconds
they did not know what they were talking
about and I've used that quark test for
years with colleagues like if you can't
tell me what you're doing and why in
less than 60 seconds it's because you're
not thinking clearly and if you can't
express it in numbers you're probably
not thinking clearly
so the quark tests at Morgan Stanley and
amongst my Google colleagues they they
know what the quark test is and I think
it's a really helpful way to try and get
a pithy answer although this is not a
pity answer so you may say did I pass
the PARCC test but you pass ok so
turning to six months ago thousands of
employees walked out of your offices
around the world after the New York
Times reported that Google paid over
ninety million dollars in exit packages
to executives accused of sexual
misconduct your team walked out - and
you went with them why so I firmly
believe that diversity and inclusion and
the highest of ethics is the way we look
to comport ourselves and we put so many
programs and policies in place to ensure
that we're continuing to to do things in
the highest-quality way and we're all in
this together and to me that was the
most important message we may not always
get things right but I think compared to
every place I've seen either as clients
or where abort I think we try at least
as hard as anyone and we are as a
leadership team are really committed to
getting it right and I just thought it
was really important to be with the team
to say we're all in this together we're
we're we'll address issues we'll solve
issues we're all in this together thank
you it's an ongoing it's an ongoing
discussion and and and that was very
interesting to be able to to hear about
it thank you you did mention it
Harrison between Wall Street and and
financial in the financial industry you
were on Wall Street when it was fearing
and being skewered by occupiers
politicians Main Street and arguably now
you're in Silicon Valley when the cannon
is turning towards tech giants amid
calls for data privacy
what learnings for from The Wall Street
context do you apply to Silicon Valley
today I think probably the most
important were there many important
lessons but one of the very important
ones is to constantly try and raise the
bar on yourself and you know for us one
of the really got important guiding and
a mantras internally is the importance
to respect the user and respect the
opportunity and we do keep trying to
raise the bar on ourselves on anything
that will address both of you know both
either of those very important guiding
principles and you bring up privacy
privacy is a great example from the
earliest days at Google there was a deep
deeply felt feeling deep ruk recognition
that privacy is sacrosanct that the data
are your data and that we need to make
that really clear and everything we do
so Google was the first to make sure
that you could take your data with you
all of the controls around privacy we do
constantly research to try and make them
as simple and streamlined as possible
and just announced changes to that again
recently and you know sundar has been
outspoken talking about the imperative
to support federal legislation around
privacy as well we did 18 months of work
leading up to the European privacy
legislation gdpr
so there are places where it's about
upping the bar on yourself and speaking
up where it makes sense for legislation
in some places it it is important to
have legislation that's a great example
in other places there are things that
companies should and could be doing
individually but I think I saw that on
Wall Street as well some companies just
kind of have in this
and I wish it was yesterday and didn't
recognize no there was a lot that needed
to change some of which should be
self-imposed and could be more rapidly
implemented if you were doing it on your
own and somewhere actually legislation
did make sense
okay so legislation is interesting to me
I have a question for you that is unique
to you you're one of the few here in
Silicon Valley who has also worked at
the Department of Justice and Treasury
and Treasury yeah well you seconded to
Treasury yes that's right after Stanford
yeah Wow there's a lot of research
you're my hero rooms I got to research
you I may have known some of this
organically they the Department of
Justice and other policy makers around
the world are debating today whether
technology companies like Google Amazon
and Facebook are monopolies as someone
who's seen both sides do you think that
there's a point at which these big tech
companies might become too big so a
quick aside I was a first year out of
Stanford intern in the Civil Division
so my answer has nothing to do
that means Jen look I think that there's
there's a lot of the question if the
reality is when you look at the
experience for consumers we're all
benefiting from ever lower prices more
access to more products we're seeing
innovation at a pace that is
extraordinary and the funding around
that it last year was at the highest
level ever so there continues to be a
really vibrant ecosystem which you know
I believe we're all benefiting from as
users great you talk about greatest
source of vulnerability what do you
think is Google's greatest source of
vulnerability so that where that comes
from
is one of the many lessons coming out
the financial crisis was that it's
imperative to identify your greatest
source of vulnerability and protect
against it in the good days and for
banks
it was liquidity without liquidity you
choke and that's what happened to
individual banks and that's what
happened to the financial system and so
then I asked myself that question when I
got out heroes kind of if I'm going to
talk about that was one of the lessons
how do you apply it to technology I
think the greatest source of
vulnerability for technology is not
continuing to invest for the long term
and focus on innovation so if you look
at the companies in technology that were
the leaders 20 years ago most of them
are not still the leaders and so it
really is this imperative around
investing for the long term and what one
of the many things I love about the
approach at alphabet from the earliest
days was really trying to think through
and seed innovative new technologies so
in the earliest days you know they came
up with an idea of 20% time if you had a
great idea let's give you 20% time to go
pursue it and out of that
for example came Gmail then was the idea
of X but it's now affectionately known
as our moonshot Factory maybe you go do
it a hundred percent of the time and you
try and come up with what is that
moonshot that's where we mow which all
of you hopefully will be in soon enough
that's what we know and our life
sciences business fairly came from and
and you know alphabet in many respects
was the third iteration we tried to come
up with a structure we came up with a
structure that said Google focus over
here and let us really continue to go
deeper in what might be those next
things that are out on the horizon but I
think it really is about the imperative
of focusing on the long term and not
getting pulled into short termism how
does alphabet when you restructure it it
in 2014 15 15 thank you how does
alphabet when you were stretch in 2015
the vision that you had for alphabet
then how does that compare to what it is
today so time doesn't stop but I think
that the main the core of it and Larry
said it well in his letter announcing
what are the goals for alphabet was
really to be able to
have google focus on the many
extraordinary challenges and
opportunities and it that it faces and
not focus on kind of the next set of
things that are being done in other bets
and you know enable Larry and Sergey to
go really deep there and so that's
that's what we've been living I have
another intersectional question for you
because you have this old hat of being a
star investment banker and now you are
you were the recent hat of leading
leading this amazing company as the CFO
what do you think of the uber IPO
Oh uber is it's an extraordinary product
I think it's changed all of our lives
and it's still very early
you know it's early days post type
pricing okay now turning turning to you
as a leader thank you
roof has seen 750 tech IPOs is that
right I was I have encountered all but
it's been a lot oh I've been counting so
you you personally spent almost 30 years
on Wall Street where you grew and
businesses and stabilized ones on the
brink of crisis and you're now here in
Silicon Valley where as you said your
positioning alphabet for long term
success what traits do you have that
enable you to be successful in two very
different worlds let me sort of reframe
that question the because I feel like
I'm thirty sounds like a long time but I
still feel like I've got a long way to
go so the book hasn't fully been written
but what do I think is important if I
were turning back the clock to when I
was exiting Wharton
I think one of the most important things
is clarity of thought and really being
able to to analyze crisply and
articulate what you think is important
and I've already said it but it's
important to use your voice at the right
time don't be in a room and not use your
voice I think for the underrepresented
groups here that can be hard and I think
it's much better today than it was when
I got out but the number of people who
would speak over me or you know sort of
to try and diminish you and I even say
it today the sámi seemed like a really
odd place to go but I think it's a
really important message for everyone
which is when people speak over you even
though that may feel like it's a small
thing it is not a small thing because
every time you're in a meeting if
somebody's saying you know I don't
really need your voice I'm gonna speak
over you after a while you sort of
internalize and say if you don't need my
voice why do you need me
and so it is really important to stake
out your place and make sure your voice
is hurt and today it's easier to do that
if someone tries to speak over me I'll
literally put my hand out you know I'll
say let me finish do that for others if
you see it happen and make sure you're
working for somebody who gives you that
space so finding your voice is really
important and then getting a sponsor
getting finding someone who will take a
risk on you and open doors for you
probably the most one that I had
throughout my career I could talk about
people who did that for me but maybe one
of the most most important other than
Bill Campbell was the conversation I had
when I was asked to take over running
the financial institutions group and I
had had a career where I covered
technology companies and media companies
and private equity companies really like
fun stuff in my view and then I was
asked to cover banks and asset managers
and insurance companies and so probably
not surprising that some of you my
reaction was wow that's really boring
why would I do that
and the person who went on to become the
president Morgan Stanley said you gotta
trust me on this it's gonna ne literally
said it's gonna open doors that you're
not even aware of I can't even tell you
what they are this was in 2006 my
instinct yet again was just wrong it was
no that sounds boring I don't want to do
it but when he said trust me on this I
said okay and then August of 2007 when
you were actually at a bank is when you
first saw the cracks in the in the
financial system and so I had not quite
a year to figure out which way was up
when it was clear there were problems on
the horizon that led to the role with
Treasury and Fed that led to the CFO
role at Morgan Stanley that led to being
out here so I think sponsors and having
that honest conversation are really
important so I'd sort of put all of that
together I understand from a
conversation I had with Jeff Immelt last
week that a former partner of yours that
you not only have a strong voice but he
is the only he said that you were the
only person that he likes to get bad
news from I gave him a lot of bad news
and to that end he said that you have an
incredible serene sense of calm that was
incredibly rare during the financial
crisis and you were the only one he saw
through through the whole storm that had
it supposed to comment no III want to
toot your horn for you because I know
you may not it was actually during that
period what was fascinating to me about
him is he kept wanting to get the bad
news and I felt when not that he wanted
to get bad news he wanted to get what I
thought was truth let me put it that way
I think he was hoping some of it would
not be bad but I also think that it's
really important on your team to make
sure that you are hearing those voices
that are telling you something you don't
want to hear and creating a space or
you're drawing all of that information
out and one of the two in the book
trillion-dollar coach one of the
comments Bill Campbell makes is always
make sure before you open as the leader
that you've made sure you hear every
voice that has not yet spoken because
often times some of the ones who are the
most quiet might actually have the new
idea the most profound idea and Jeff
always wanted to hear whatever I was
concerned about whatever the thought was
it was the challenge to him to the way
he was trying to think about it and I
think that's an important lesson for us
thank you
you may know that role playing is a
time-honored tradition here at the GSB
well we got to do it well okay
might you indulge me yes please go so
Donald Trump calls he needs a leader who
knows markets and technology no one
better than you he says Ruth I need you
to come on as my Treasury secretary what
do you say well that call has in common
I'm really focused on what I'm doing
right now so thank you for humoring me
let me let me now turn it over to my
friends in the audience to ask you to
ask you their own questions
hi Ruth thank you for being here today
you spoke a lot about having a good
sponsor what were the things that you
looked for in a sponsor that you
identified someone who is smart and
extremely ethical so when they were
solving a problem they were thinking
about what I also needed it wasn't just
being expedient and solving one of their
problems somebody I could learn from you
know early in my career at Morgan
Stanley I worked on a deal with somebody
who never took me to even internal
meetings and after a pretty long period
of time he took me to an internal
meeting and the senior person on the
deal team the partner turned to him and
pointed at me and said is this the I I
keep hearing about and made it really
clear that he had for months been taking
credit for all of my work and I said you
know what that's got to stop right now
and so I thought of one of the smartest
people in the department he had a
reputation for being really difficult
but I knew I could learn from him and I
went to him and said I want to work on
anything you have whatever it might be I
just I want to learn from you I've heard
like you're amazing people like
compliments and so he said okay and so
he ended up putting me on a deal and the
first deal was a pretty crummy deal but
we we I learned a ton from him he
actually is the person who got me on
that Gillette deal he then opened the
door and working on something that was
that marki opened another door that was
the first time I had somebody who I
think actually said let me give it a go
so you have to prove yourself to the
person oftentimes people will come up to
me and say will you be my sponsor and to
me that's almost akin to saying can we
have a child on the first date no you
can't like first let's have a date
want to have a second date then maybe
you know further down the line we can
talk about that so you do have to earn
the right to have that kind of a
relationship it's a two-way relationship
the other thing I learned early in my
career I was so grateful to somebody who
was a sponsor so grateful for all the
doors that he was opening and then I
realized you know what he's getting at
least as much out of this as I am
because I'm great operating leverage for
him because he's giving me stretch goals
so I'm super excited I'm like learning
I'm like it's it's amazing to be in a
position where you're feeling like
you're growing so it's really a two-way
street and recognizing that as well but
to your question you earn it and make
sure the person's really smart respected
and super ethical
hi Ruth you have a lot of very unique
experiences not the least of which
having been worked both in the private
well in a private sector at the Treasury
and during the financial crisis
presumably also interacted a lot with
academics who were also advising the
government at the time how would you
compare and contrast the different ways
in which the government the private
sector and the academic institutions
lead and shape our world it's a great
question
like for me one of the most important
things is to find a place where you care
about the mission of the organization
you're part of whether it's in the
public sector or the private sector
being mission driven is a critical
element of it what was intriguing when
you're working with the public sector is
that oftentimes it's tough to to look at
you have different constituents who are
judging what are the outcomes and you're
trying you need to balance sort of
perception elements as much as the
content elements of it how is it going
to land because you have so many public
constituents that are looking at what
you're doing but I think in each
instance if I go back to the work at
Treasury what were the key elements it
goes back to exactly what I was doing
with with public private sector clients
it's what are the analytics around any
judgment you know how much capital is
needed in something well you need to put
data around it we ended up as an example
running Mortgage Analytics to figure out
how big the whole could be 24 hours a
day in three locations around the globe
because we didn't have enough time to
just do it normal way and yet it was the
analytics that were important so I
really feel like in any setting
what are you solving for what's the data
that's going to help you make the best
decision and who can you pull in for the
best advice and this instinct based on
experience whether it's academics public
market private market is what's needed
Hank Paulson on these weekends we were
down there he literally would pop in and
out of our conference room with ideas
and those ideas it was because he had
instinct based on experience and we were
just looking for whatever the least
worst solution was and so it was this
mix of public-private that actually
helped inform how do we move forward so
I'm not sure if I fully answered it but
I don't view them as ads distinct
because it's problem-solving for
something that's important hi Ruth I had
a question around the large bets that
Google continues to make so Google
consistently is obviously played a role
buying large companies YouTube Android
and over the past few years maybe has
invested less so and some of these
transformational bets I would be curious
to know as Google continues to grow and
the core business continues to be
something to think about do you think
transformational bets are important
whether acquisitions strategic
investments or another strategy I
absolutely think in as I said a couple
of times now investing for the long term
is imperative and it needs to be it
needs it needs to be of a scale that
matters that can make a difference kid
that can really improve lives and so
your your frame of the question well
which is bets both organic and
acquisition and I think both are
fruitful we're investing quite
aggressively in a number of areas that
we do view as important long term
opportunities for us so one of the most
exciting areas is what's going on with
the cloud right now and we may have
started later than we should have but we
have the core engineering pillars that
are critical it's you know it's the
technical infrastructure of the data
analytics it's security it's
collaborative tools it's the machine
learning opportunity we needed to bring
it together and we're investing
meaningfully because our view is that
we're very early globally in this move
to the cloud and it's an absolutely
transformative one it opens up new new
opportunities for every business as they
think about what are the efficiencies
and tools and that they can
if it from and so that as an example is
a really important area you look at the
way where we're all using devices today
and how do you think about what are
these home devices and have searched was
its desktop its mobile it's also what
are the home devices the one has that
enable you to to get whatever you want
from brought the Google home and
hopefully you all have a listen to music
get recipes do whatever you want to do
phone calls so these are you know that
our hardware effort is important what
we're doing with YouTube and
subscriptions and YouTube TV is
important what we're doing with way Mo's
important we're doing a lot in health
which is probably one of the most
exciting areas when you think about
applying machine learning so absolutely
when we look at it we've got an
extraordinary business in what we're
doing with search we're continuing to
build on that through investments in
machine learning and then we're layering
on some newer areas and if you're going
to continue to invest for the long term
you need to keep seating those they
don't need to all the acquisition we do
a lot of acquisitions but you need to
keep thinking about where the world can
go or where you want to take it ok one
last question please can people hear you
though the oak hole with sidewalk labs
yes
[Laughter]
could you talk about being a sponsor now
that you're more senior and how you
decide to allocate that time and what
that looks like for you I'm sorry go
back to so to be can you talk about how
how you're a sponsor now that you are in
a senior position and how you allocate
your time and what that looks like for
you
so I thought your gonna ask a sidewalk
question for those of you don't know
sidewalk is looking at reimagining what
is a city and how do we think about
every element of it from mobility to
building to affordable housing and this
question about where does this go I
think it's a really exciting one for its
society it kind of ties into some of the
things we're doing with Wemo what if you
don't need to spend the kind of
Stanford spends and others do on parking
garages and you can and put that into
schools and education and playgrounds
I'm gonna come to your question I
promise but like when you said 500 my
god there's a lot going on in the world
of reimagining what can life be let
alone the number of lives that can be
saved when you go to self-driving cars
but you have two different questions
sponsors look I think that to me it's
exciting when you look at people who are
trying to figure out where to next I as
I've said many times I am so grateful
and can name so many sponsors who've
really been key to my career so my view
is that I try and spend time every week
and in structured settings and that
individually or with groups because I
think there are a couple ways that you
can go about actually helping people as
they're thinking about what next and
it's really about and investing in
someone's career and helping them
understand what are their options to me
we owe it to our teams to understand
what the career kind of the arc of a
career can be I'm literally going
through with my team now so we're and my
question is on a scale of 1 to 10 where
10 is high and 1 is low how happy are
you we how long do you want to be here
what do you want next what's important
to you and those conversations are
really valuable conversations I like to
set the tone and and drive those and
that to me is about sponsoring my team
but then I'm also sending out a note to
all of my team that's okay I just
finished that if I have the time to do
it I want my team to be doing it with
their team and so ensuring you're in a
place where those types of practices
cascade is really important ruth half of
us here will have graduated next month
congratulations all of you why we see
the hands from the about to graduate Wow
awesome awesome very exciting a lot of
exciting things out of you I will assure
you that I had no idea I would be in
this role when I was the equivalent of
your seat and life is really wonderful
I'm fine you are our last hope for our
final view from the top wisdom I thought
I'd ask you some questions that I know
are keeping us all up at night are you
are you ready for a lightning round sure
go for it okay watch Game of Thrones or
eat ice cream at Sultan's draw Oh what
if I don't do either my husband likes
Game of Thrones my kids like he would
throw and he gives me a couple hour
break to go do what I want
[Laughter]
Iceland is a fun trip if you want to go
there so yeah that's the truth excellent
how about going to tech or finance mmm
well I found my cake and eat it too
because I'm doing both but look I think
that go I view this is a maybe a little
old-fashioned but I I tell my kids this
still so I hope it's good advice I feel
like the experiences you're about to
have are a paid postgraduate education
don't view it as please you said on
average it's five years and then you go
do something else be at the place where
you can learn a time you're proud to be
there it has the ethics and culture you
want and you're working with someone
extraordinary who knows where that's
going to take you and if that is tech
first or finance first and it resonates
with you you are not shutting doors who
are opening doors and just like being
here at GSB opens more doors for you
just make sure that that's what you're
doing because you're on a journey and
your very very early and so I am firmly
of the view I wouldn't have had this
opportunity had I not done my prior one
and one thing led to another so I'm not
trying to skirt your answer but I really
think it is more about the people and
quality of what you're doing rather than
should it be tech or healthcare or
something else unless you have this
unbelievable like commitment and dying
passion for that should we pay off
student debt or invest in retirement
savings
Wow I get rid of that student debt we do
the rest later
should we have kids now or later yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
should we join a company or found a
company oh man
you know I would have been a horrible
founder of a company and I'm not so bad
at a company but there others who are
just the opposite again don't regret
anything I remember early on reading
Jeff Bezos no regrets point which is
when he was looking to leave de sha
hedge fund to create this crazy idea
this book seller I think his parents
said to him what are you doing that you
know I don't know if he paid off his
student loans at that point but he said
I don't want have regrets I'd rather try
and fail and never try it all so I think
at the note you know the regrets
analysis is actually really good don't
ever regret something you've got plenty
of time big data or bite-sized data I
think there's a lot of is phenomenal
that we're we're living in like we
haven't talked that much about AI and
machine learning but we are living in an
extraordinary and Minot's with some ice
let's have one face no it's okay we're
living in an extraordinary time you know
when I look at what AI machine learning
and building on data can do it's not
only the fun stuff like if you were
using one of our pixel phones and our
photos Google photos you can take
pictures and sort by person by hug by
whatever you want you can go to any
country and translate into any language
but you also to me what's super exciting
is what's going on I've already
mentioned it with healthcare you know as
an example one of the most amazing areas
it's what's going on with with scans and
pathology reports reading reports in the
area of breast cancer we just recently
had this extraordinary breakthrough
where the accuracy of diagnosing stages
of breast cancer is meaningfully better
with the tools of
machine learning and I you know adds an
example I think it's in one of four
instances when doctors are reading
pathology reports they over a different
periods of time they changed their
diagnosis of the staging staging is
critical because it tells you what kind
of intervention is needed how far along
you are and what's also extraordinary is
the percentage of time they miss early
stages of metastatic cancer is actually
quite remarkable from our early research
what we're seeing is in almost all cases
when you're looking at pathology reports
biopsies you the machine learning is
able to come up with what in our science
of early stage metastatic cancer why is
this so exciting because it's building
on data in ways that is a tool for
doctors and what they're saying is this
enables them to focus on the tough stuff
it enables them to go deeper it enables
them to know when to intervene at an
early space as a cancer survivor myself
I look at this and I say it's sort of
akin to letting doctors have the tools
they need to be as effective as possible
and spend time with patients the way
they want so I get excited about these
things because I look at the ability to
transform care and I look at what we
have being at Stanford or what I had
being in New York it's amazing not
everyone around the world lives in
places as extraordinary as this and so
really to provide that kind of access to
quality diagnosis amazing one more story
I was with a doctor recently and I asked
him about this and he said it's amazing
the ability with the ability to see
what's going on in my patient's body on
a continuous basis rather than just the
15 minutes or 30 minutes they're with me
I am that much better and so I look at
that and I say we're living in an
amazing time and to be able to leverage
this the right way to to address whether
it's healthcare or you know deaths on
the road from cars one thing after
another it's pretty extraordinary what
we're able to do
you know I think we're gonna look back
on this and say wow it's how much more
can we apply thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]